all right before we get started fair
warning I'm gonna talk about some
spoilers in this review not all of them
which is funny with spoilers you feel
like you should commit or just do none
but there are some moments that will
have some spoilers however a side note
didn't take me a year to get this up so
these are improvements stranger things
season 2 so stranger things season 2
picks up about a year after the first
one ended a crew of young D&D nerds are
together again and with the addition of
another one the girls known as Mad Max
in a baffling display of how you
integrate a new character into an
already established group totally works
but the basic premise in this season is
will the kid who disappeared to the
upside down in the first season is still
connected to the upside down and he's
having these dreams or vision point is
the upside down is coming for him and
bad things are about to happen and the
organization Matthew Modine pop up from
the first season the one he worked for
they're all like hey we're good now but
they're still there are things happening
that they're not telling everybody what
was season 2 there are things I like
things I didn't what I like is the
talent involved everybody in this show
is great and they're only gonna get
better
watching Millie Bobbie Brown the one who
plays 11 watching her act reminds me of
when I saw Haley Joel Osment in the
sixth sense
I don't know what that means for
longevity sake but I'm just saying when
I watch her that's the feeling I guess
also David Harbor who plays the sheriff
season two concentrates on him a bit
more I mean he had ample time in the
first season but he has a whole arc in
here that really is meant for him and he
dated me to my core man couple times
like waterworks are coming they're
coming I think it'll be great as hell oh
boy but even if Hellboy is so good I'll
remember him is Jim hopper forever and
this show keeps up the balance of horror
and humor mostly from Dustin that kid
has great comedic timing he can break
the tension in intense scenes in a very
real way suppose what I like most about
season 2 is it shows events change
people will is not the same kid he was
before he was trapped in the upside-down
mike is not the same kid he was since he
lost 11 there's some straight-up PTSD
going around with these characters I
like that it's very easy for a show to
be like alright that's done well now
what we're all the same it's fine no no
people are not the same a couple of
times the editing was great too there
were these moments where information is
coming together and it's editing back to
the foreshadowing tying that into the
revelation
sometimes shows the movies do it because
they have to weave it in otherwise
people wouldn't make the connection
that's not the
with stranger things I felt like you
could make the connection without it
just editing it like that made it just a
little more slick with stranger things
season 2 to us right is the concept of
with every action there is a reaction 11
making that breach making contact with
the upside down that's a big deal and it
will have great effects on our world
where a season one was a more personal
approach with a kid missing 11 making
friends friends making friends with 11 a
mom trying to find her son this is the
beginning of the reaction of that
contact that will probably carry us
through season 4 but if I'm talking
about what I didn't like right out the
gate I felt like this season took a few
episodes to find its Grove season want a
stranger things from the get-go I was
like oh I'm in every episode since then
just brought me in with intrigue if I'm
more intrigued I'm more intrigued by the
end of that season I was like I'm the
most intrigued of intrigue I need to see
season 2 season 2 though plays the long
con it does pay off by the end but until
about Episode five you're like were they
going with all of this
I liked the integration of the new girl
max into the group her douchey brother
who I didn't recognize for the longest
time I had to IMDB em I was like who is
he oh [ __ ] he's Jason from the Power
Rangers movie he's one of the most
disgustingly horrifying high school
students I've ever seen in a movie or
show he's just a complete dick he's the
kind of person you're scared to be on
the bus with I don't feel like there was
too much payoff with this character
however I imagine it setting up for
season 3 for a little bit for Elevens
character I was like why are you in this
season I get why she's in the season
again by the end it paid off but really
she's in this season her arc exists to
expand David harbours character which
works for David harbors character but
when you have David harbors character
and 11 otherwise known as the telepath
who was born and bred to be a
super-government death weapon if you
have her with him only to expand his
character I feel like you're only doing
half the picture justice before the
comments-section lights up I know why
it's important for him to have that arc
with 11 his daughter and everything but
I also think it was really stupid for
him to have all the information about
Elevens mom in the cabin where he's
keeping her I felt like that was just
really convenient really I felt like 11
in season 2 was kind of like Sylar in
season 2 of Heroes where it's like
you're in season 2 because you kicked so
much ass on the first season kind of
stole the show so we have to have you in
season 2
I feel like it would have been a cleaner
ending for her if she died with the
demagogue on at the end of season 1 like
she's in it I don't want to see stranger
things with
11 I just feel like the reintegration of
11 into the show could have been smooth
thing is how she never even meets up
with the crew until the very very end
other than that she's hanging out in a
cabin and it also feeds into episode 7
which I'm not gonna lie I didn't hate
that episode as much as the internet
told me I was supposed to hate the
episode doesn't change the fact that
that episode were 11 hooks up with that
gang to commit crimes totally reminded
me of short circuit 2 where Johnny 5
hooks up with that gang to commit crimes
it was totally short circuit to which
you could probably say it well that's
the point a lot of things in this show
or throwbacks but I saw throw backs to
aliens
I saw throwback to the Exorcist you're
gonna have throw backs to go throw back
to them don't do a throwback to short
circuit - she didn't need to hook up
with that gang to find her way back she
could've just been like oh they're in
trouble I see that I'm gonna go there
from the cabin and the reason that
episode at least for me for my
perception feels unfulfilled is because
the first thing that happens in a show
in a season really is meant to establish
where we're going the first thing that
happens is you see this other girl use
her powers for her and her gang to evade
the cops and it doesn't touch on them at
all after that until seven episodes
later and if that episode was completely
taken out of this season really the
season would be no different so you
really feel like the show lied to you
from the get-go I think it's really cool
that there are other kids out there by
implication eleven is named eleven which
means there are at least ten other ones
but you feel like that's nothing but
setup for season three because in the
end stranger things season two paid off
by the end but for the first half of it
I was like all right let's pick it up
and I get a show doing the long con
where it's alright it's time to build I
felt stranger things season 1 was
absolutely that not like season 1 of
stranger things was action-packed
stranger things season 1 was all build
but it was a very intriguing build I
liked the second half of season 2 a lot
more than the first half of season 2
that's when I am sup the stakes you
really see where they're going but the
crew really carries it these kids are
immensely talented young adults I hated
being called a kid when I was their age
so there's that if you think I hated
season 2 I feel like I didn't Ella
straight my point correctly and for that
I apologize I liked it I just didn't
love it as much as the first season but
you should really check it out the
internet loves season 2 every bit as
much if not more than season 1 I feel
like I'm in the minority here but I want
to know what you guys think you like
season 2 more than
and one or one more than season -
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]